اذا قرار الدول الغربيه وعلى راسها واشنطن
وبارين بارسال دبابات قتال متطوره ليست
العقده الوحيده التي كانت تواجدك فالخطوه
الاصعب تتمثل بكيفيه نقل هذه المركبات
المدرعه الثقيله الى كياب وفقا صحيفه
شحنه معظم الاسلحه سيما الدبابات سيتم اما
على عربات سكك حديديه او شاحنات مسطحه
قويه بما يكفي لتحمل وزن هذه الدبابات
لكنها سكك الحديديه عموما هي الطريقه
الاسرع والاكثر امانا لنقل المعدات نظرا
لان القوافل الطويله من الشاحنات المسطحه
ستجذب انتباه روسيا هذا ان تم غض النظر عن
المشاكل التي تواجهها سكك الحديد
الاوكرانيه حاليا وتتمثل المخاوف مشاهدينا
ايضا استهداف الروسيه للطرق او اماكن
انطلاق المعدات اثناء الشحنها الى الخطوط
الاماميه في وجنوب اوكرانيا كما ان قياده
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه الاخرى الى
ساحه المعركه سيستغرق المزيد من الوقت
والوقود وقطع الغيار وقد تصبح هدفا متحركه
لطائرات الروسيه وتعد عمليه تسليم الاسلحه
الغربيه والمعدات العسكريه الاخرى الى
اوكرانيا واحده من اكبر اسرار الحرب
حراساتها مشدده وعاد ما تكون متخفيه في
ظلام لتفادي الهجوم عليها